avec les fêtes de fin d'année il y a
fool dans la route nationale de tours et
la cohabitation avec le tramway est
parfois difficile entre piétons tête en
l'air ou cyclistes imprudents
les conducteurs de tram doivent
s'adapter plus d'un piéton s'est déjà
fait surprendre par ce transport peut
être un peu trop discret je me suis dit
ça y est on est tous et j'avais pas fais
attention qui avait le tramway en fait
les bye baby paix parce que sinon là
avec le casque sur les oreilles ils
arrivent derrière on ne voit pas je me
retourne j'attende mais là le petit coup
de presse et je repars sur le côté les
chauffeurs sont plus vigilants ils
roulent parfois moins de 10 kilomètres
heure pour pouvoir arrêter plus
facilement les 50 tonnes de l'arabe mais
selon certains commerçants témoin
privilégié heureusement qu'il ya la
petite sonnerie dans la partie de la rue
nationale
le train de m'en klaxons façonne en
tenir un cap town qui klaxonnent journée
hormis un suicide en avril dernier le
tram n'a causé aucun accident grave
depuis son lancement
l'entreprise fille bleus qui gère le
réseau a lancé une campagne de
prévention pour avertir davantage les
piétons